elle est trop belle regarde non mais
c'était incroyable ils disent des choses
comme ça merci il est là bonjour C'est
Marie-Hélène je vais répondre à vos
commentaires donna Madonna faut la
retrouver elle est adorable écoute ça y
est on a retrouvé adorable je ne sais
pas mais c'est moi Marie-Hélène j'habite
à Marseille dans un beau village il fait
beau vivre je t'invite à venir me voir
Alexis dit je suis une femme une femme à
mariée bah oui mais ça a raté ta bouche
pourquoi ça a raté mais parce que moi
j'ai senti un autre appel et puis voilà
ben je suis devenu religieuse mais bon
c'est pas mal non plus ça me fait rire
qu'elle parle d'abord de ses vaches
avant de parler de sa famille et bah oui
tu vois c'est quelque chose
moi aussi ça me fait drôle j'en ai un
peu honte mais bon tu sais ma famille
était bien plus présente dans mon cœur
que les vaches elle sait faire beaucoup
de choses semble en être fier et elle a
bien raison c'est compétences sont
utiles et son habille régionale et
charmant aussi mais j'étais quand même
belle c'est vrai